[Laughter]
[Applause]
i will fix this
pregnancy i promise
okey dokey neighbor happy one division
day folks
there's a lot to get into with this
episode so spectacular spoilers ahead
i'm carlos bustamante and this
is canada's nerve
we start off with an in your face
malcolm in the middle style opening
credits scene which works as a clever
way
to tell us that the boys are going to be
playing an even bigger role this episode
the show makes its biggest stylistic
shift here going from single cam to a
modern multi-camera approach
complete with flashbacks fourth wall
breaking moments and everything
and like the past episodes wandavision
does a great job of mimicking its source
material like
this is a genuinely funny sitcom it
works
where's your costume tommy this is my
costume i'm the cool twin
what does that make me it's halloween in
west view and we have got to start
by talking about the characters costumes
i love the comic book references we get
here wanda and vision look like they're
doing a budget vision in scarlet witch
cosplay
explaining the getups as a mexican
wrestler and a sokovian fortune teller
pietro does a spot on classic
quicksilver complete with comic's
accurate hair
beautiful and billy and tommy give us a
nod to the characters potential futures
as wiccan and speed
members of the young avengers this is it
game time
it is if you're a winner side note i am
here
for the slow build to this young
avengers team like
let's go the neighborhood watch is the
only thing that stands between the trees
and the toilet paper no that's not what
you're supposed to do
lots of interesting developments happen
with this core family in episode six
after his discovery his last episode and
the confrontation with juan that vision
is a changed man
the synthesized man moana doesn't really
have control over him like she did
before which seems
unsettling for her and he uses his
independence to dig deeper into the
mysteries of their current situation
the boy is now 10 years old have
distinct personalities and somehow
manifest their individual powers
tommy was super speed just like his
uncle and billy with telepathy
just like mom evan peters pietro is
still here after his grand entrance last
week
use the cool sleep till the afternoon
spend time with the kid's uncle that
tommy in particular idolizes
yeah kick ass i feel the need fuss me
kick ass did they just double down on
kick ass
like the movie kick-ass that both
quicksilver actors aaron taylor johnson
and evan peters appeared in
together how meta is this show gonna get
you're testing me no i'm not hey
it's cool i know i look different all
right as expected having petro on board
complicates things he's self-aware
all the time and unlike the regular
residents of west view doesn't seem to
be playing a role other than who he
appears to be
i got shot like a chump in the street
for no reason at all and next thing i
know
i heard you calling me
i knew you needed me he knows that he
was brought here somehow he knows wanda
envisions history
and he even knows how he himself died
there's clearly something fishy going on
there though and
wanda like us should probably stay
suspicious
also there's this unleash hell demon
spawn
now for those of you on the piacho's
actually mephisto bandwagon doesn't this
lion just
jump out at you like why else would you
say it like that
wanda in this episode is preoccupied to
put it lightly
with vision off playing detective and
the boys growing up and getting their
powers and her previously dead brother
now crashing on her couch
her focus is pulled in more directions
than ever before
she spends most of the episode trying to
come to grips with pietro being back in
her life
clearly grappling with whether or not
she should trust him as he asks
a lot of questions about exactly what
kind of control she has over westview
i'm impressed seriously it's a pretty
big leap from giving people nightmares
and shooting red wiggly woos out your
hands
how'd you even do all this everyone's
been asking these questions
including vision and as he gets further
and further from wanda he gets closer
and closer
to some truly spooky stuff giving us a
moment we've been waiting
a long time for
am i dead no no
why would you think that because you are
[Music]
while things are weird inside the hex
outside
it's downright scarlet chaos hayward is
making plans for an attack on rwanda
while monica wants to find another way
then
hayward says this maybe it's a good
thing you weren't here when your mother
died
because clearly you don't have the
stomach for this job
this guy crossing the line now theories
are going around about the various super
villains hayward could be but even if
he's just
a regular dude this proves he's a
straight-up piece of
language work cap
i was gonna say work so now monica darcy
and jimmy are off the team but they're
not off the case
they sneak around and discover that
hayward has been keeping his own tabs on
vision
and a secret intel that no one else has
laid eyes on with her mystery contact on
the way monica is determined to go back
in the hecks and help wanda
however darcy finds some startling info
and tries to warn her against it
you've gone through the boundary twice
already monica the energy inside has
rewritten your cells
on a molecular level twice it's changing
you
monica is clearly thinking of her
mother's cancer in this case but comic
fans can see
this is likely the way monica gets the
powers that she uses as the superhero
photon
or spectrum or captain marvel i don't
know they have a lot of names to choose
from
now poking around hayward's files darcy
happens upon classified weapon intel on
something called
cataract now let's see the tesseract
was the vessel for the space stone and a
cataract affects your vision
does hayward want to use vision as a
weapon
i mean the math checks out back in
westview we get the standout moment in
an episode
filled with standout moments after his
encounter with agnes vision finds the
edge of town the barrier between the hex
and reality and not knowing what's on
the other side
makes his way through now unlike wanda
in the previous episode
vision's not in control here as he tries
to break through
the hex pulls out tearing him apart
almost as if most of what he
is now is a product of the anomaly all
the while
hayward just stands there watching like
the piece of
language work he is
we then get to see wanda at a power
level we've never seen before
as she extends the hex beyond the
borders of west view engulfing darcy
and the sword base camp in the process
so
was this the best episode yet how do we
feel about pietro
um who's handing out candy at wanda and
vision's house
and can someone please explain that
twisted commercial to me that one's
gonna give me nightmares
now if you like this video please give
us a like and subscribe
for even more videos i'm carlos you can
follow me on instagram at low spot
have a good one folks i'll see you next
[Music]
time
you